here in this video we will showcase all
the 11 aquatic monsters of the monster
verse
just a reminder we have done a video
about the five oceanic titans of the
monsterverse last year but since then
there have been others that have been
revealed to us and we will also include
the large subtitles as well in this list
so subscribe if you haven't and now
let's get down to business
the first one the maya squid seen in
kong skull island of 2017 it isn't
really a titan but maybe just a subtitle
judging by its size or maybe a gigantis
it was first seen fighting kong and it
was the first creature to fight skong
one on one in skull island it lives in
the waterways of that island as well as
the ocean surrounding it my squids
resemble a colossal cross between a
squid and an octopus their heads
resemble that of an octopus and they
have eight long arms lined with suction
cups their jaws resemble that of a beak
which can spin at great speeds this
creature is around 110 feet long
the second one the janitor seen in gvk
dominion this is a new monster
classified as a sub-diamond species and
not a titan since it wasn't as large as
the others it was however the alpha of
its own swarm of deadly donklister
species of fishes that are each as large
as a killer whale or so
genital
greatly resembles a dunkleosteus but it
was maybe 150 feet long or so its body
is blue and it has red fins with two
arms ending in claws its massive inner
teeth like bony plates jut towards from
its jaws
number three the tiamat this titan seen
in gvk dominion almost got the upper
hand in a fight against the king of the
monsters in their battle underwater she
could be termed as the queen of the
oceans and was way longer than the big g
as well as having hydrokinetic powers
she is a titanic serpentine creature it
is light blue in coloration with vibrant
purple scales these scales are serrated
and knife-like her skull is draconic
with yellow eyes and four barbells
extending from its sides extending from
near her head are two wing-like fins and
she was visibly longer than the king of
the monsters which would make her around
a thousand feet long
fourthly we have nakika this titan was
read about in the novelization of
godzilla vs kong and was then seen in
gvk dominion but was one of the 17
titles stated in the 2019 movie king of
the monsters it was back then named as
the kraken but was later renamed as
nakika she looks like a massive octopus
with a dense curving cone of shell that
protects her massive brain in dominion
nakika is revealed to have at least
eight thick tentacles akin with multiple
rows of suckers bright blue eyes and
insecticidal face an internal shell and
a colorful iridescent skin
next we have the leviathan the leviathan
was one of the titans that were
monitored by monarch during the events
of king of the monsters but broke loose
out of the containment facility and
somehow through the hollow earth made
its way from scotland to the indian
ocean not much is known about this
island except for that it was maybe the
inspiration for the legendary loch ness
monster and also that it is aquatic in
nature
then we go to scilla still is a giant
armored cephalopod with brown coloration
six very long bony and lightly haired
legs each with two joints and ending
with a claw and with small spikes
growing out of the first joints she also
has a plated mantle with 10 tendrils and
a pair of orange eyes titanosilla is 341
feet tall and was first seen in godzilla
king of the monsters awakening from
nevada usa it was also seen in dominion
attacking ships but was ass-kicked by
godzilla himself and sent into hiding
next we have the swarm locus swarm docus
are ambush predators around 22 to 28
feet long that lie upside down in the
water and extend their wood like claws
to the surface before using them to
grasp on unsuspecting prey the swarm
locus are found in skull island and they
blend so perfectly to its natural
environment that it is hard to estimate
how populous they are
these submerged insecticides extend
their woody limbs above the surface
making them indistinguishable from the
abundant wetland foliage surrounding
them
number 8 siren jaws also known as
gigantus crocodilia they are huge
reptilian kaiju who are seen firstly in
the skull island the birth of kong a
monsterverse comic the siren jaws are
huge crocodilian-like creatures with
small orange eyes and big jaws filled
with razor-sharp teeth that are covered
with plant life the organism resembles
an island when immersed in water the
siren jaws plant light form blends in
with its surroundings allowing unwary
prey to walk right into their jaws they
are around 45 to 65 feet in length
next we have mock jager markuger is an
aquatic scaly reptilian thailand similar
to godzilla about the size of a very
large wheel maybe around 100 feet long
she has a flat face with her nostrils
above her human-like eyes like some
aquatic mammals and her skull produces
backwards shielding from her neck in
death mark yeager appears burnt with a
skeleton showing a jagged riff running
from her neck to her abdomen before the
events of godzilla king of the monsters
mark yeager is believed to have been
killed by an unknown titan but most say
it was godzilla
on the 10th spot we have amhulu this is
a powerful demonic looking tyrant black
in coloration with 10 yellow eyes four
tendril-like appendages extend from his
face and goes backwards his hands are
made out of vine like flesh capable of
extending to tremendous lengths his jaws
are filled with needle-like teeth and a
tongue with a spike
blue veins can be seen all throughout
his body and he has four tree-like legs
he was seen in dominion defeating
behemoth and then getting his ass
whooped by godzilla he would be more
than 300 feet tall and could survive
just as easily underwater as on land
just like godzilla
and lastly number 11 godzilla and yes
the big g is an aquatic titan since he
spends most of his time underwater and
swimming the world's oceans though
technically a reptile and not an
amphibian godzilla has an amphibious
lifestyle he spends half of his life in
water and the other on land which makes
him adept in combating in both
environments he is almost 400 feet tall
and is around 850 feet long godzilla has
displayed as being able to breathe
underwater using his gills so he can
stay underwater indefinitely
and so with that we come to the end of
the video of the 11 aquatic monsters of
the monsterverse do remember to hit that
like button for support and subscribe to
be a part of the mind cue family also
ring that bell icon for regular updates
when we post new monster content right
here on this channel
till the next one take care fam